guten abend halo 3 verbessert ich
beginne jetzt auf die cdu siegesfeier
wie die partie aber bist du nicht hast
du nicht ein spd parteibuch das habe ich
leider verlegt ich hatte mal ein
das habe ich in der form viel spaß
[Applaus]
forums richtig so so quasi wie science
fiction ist können sie sich schon
vorstellen zu sagen was ist eigentlich
eigentlich vollkommen gagas zu sagen den
satz ministerpräsident armin laschet
es ist etwas neues aber wenn wir es
aussprechen ist es total schön können
sich ja ich kann schon ministerpräsident
armin laschet du zuerst spd ja was mit
ihm los wiederholten fragen erfahrung
wieder rückschritte in der
möglichkeitsform und ich in der kurzen
form
du musst dich endlich angewöhnt gehört
zu uns wir haben jetzt verloren so ist
das auch bei niederlagen
man rettet den wahnsinn die erotische
ausstrahlung von armin laschet gewesen
sein
erotik dieser mann aus weil jetzt
natürlich die frage stellt wem
steintreppe jetzt noch mal meine frau
meine töchter dickel mir die frage
beantworten
jetzt ist man sexy denn martin schulz
für gehört ja gar nicht mehr gibt gar
nicht wirklich das was im vergleich aber
weiter aktiv sein
aber warum ja warum denn das will dieses
rote büchlein damit übereinstimmen da
kann man doch gar nicht anders geht nur
um die politischen ziele insgeheim seien
auch mal sagt schön dass er einfach weg
gekriegt wie niemand proben
sozialdemokraten verlieren und
christdemokraten gewinnen oder ist
natürlich eine heimliche schadenfreude
wenn man das so sagen da stets dabei
aber ich glaube ja dass nach
christlichen ein positives signal für
die bundestagswahl für die spd habe den
klaren vorweggenommen ich mach's nochmal
weil vom 1
ein positives signal für die
bundestagwahl leider nicht für die spd
die landbevölkerung und wir werden das
auch wenn man die wahlergebnisse
analysierte der kleinen sehen natürlich
bei allen dingen die abwahl der grünen
als ein riesenvorteil angeboten gleich
wieder ohne ohne schlechte kriegt
einfach mal wieder denken können
foto schlechtes gewissen steak essen sie
können auch sie können auch große
schlechtes gewissen eine bratwurst essen
sie können feiern essen sie können alles
essen was sie wollen
wir haben als wir die musik vor die
menschen vor schließung zu machen wie
sie zu leben haben das ist jetzt vorbei
die cdu wird auch heute nur darauf
hinaus dass du nicht nur die nähe dich
sondern dass wir auch mit teppich bleibt
ihr couscous ja gut schnitt auch
wirklich alle hören zu müssen
lustenberger foul
[Applaus]